Griese fans are having a mini meltdown  over a theory that sandy is dead  throughout the movie and actress Sarah  Michelle Gellar is one of them she  addressed the dark theory on Facebook  Wednesday writing quote wait this has  blown my mind at the end of the movie  Danny and Sandy fly off in a red  convertible as they wave goodbye to  their friends on the solid ground below  leading to the conclusion that the  flying car was the final result of  Sandy's fantasies as in she is dead the  39 year old actress breaks down the fan  theory further listen to these lines  from summer nights quote the line I  saved her life she nearly drowned  suggests that sandy actually did drown  and the whole movie is an elaborate  musical fantasy due to the lack of  oxygen getting to her brain so is sandy  driving off into the sunset with her bow  or headed to heaven in the flying red  convertible at the end of the movie let  us know your thoughts on twitter at ET  now  you